- I want to steal your wardrobe.
You're the most fun person I maybe have ever met.
I love you.
- Thank you, there looks like there's police in here.
- [Kelly] Yes, yes.
(audience laughing)
- [Sho Madjozi] You can't steal.
- This is actually intervention.
No, I'm just kidding, I'm kidding.
- Oh no.
- [Kelly] I'm just kidding.
No but Sho Madjozi, that's not your real name right?
- No, no
- What's your real name?
- Maya.
- Maya?
So, where did you get the name Maya?
- Well, I'm from South Africa but when I was born
my parents were reading Doctor Maya Angelou
and I think they wanted a daughter who was literate, so...
(Kelly laughs)
- So they said "Lets name her after someone who writes
beautifully" and yeah, that's why.
- Oh my gosh that's amazing.
- You are literally Kelly Clarkson though.
(everyone laughs)
- I know but I'm not Maya Angelou.
I'm just saying that's cool.
- But you're Kelly Clarkson, are you aware of this?
- I'm not, aim higher I swear.
But thank you, you flew...
I have gone to South Africa many times,
that is a long flight.
- [Sho] Yeah.
- So thank you for flying clear across the world
to be here.
We were very, very excited.
But tell me about your John Cena song.
What inspired it?
I love the video.
- Thank you.
- I love the song.
- Thank you so much.
I love John Cena.
- [Kelly] I love it.
(audience cheers)
- [Kelly] There you go.
- [Sho] So...
(audience claps)
I do, I do.
- Where, so did, are you a wrestling fan?
- Oh absolutely. - Is that were this came from?
- [Kelly] Okay, okay.
- Growing up I was already...
I grew up in a very rural area, Limpopo in South Africa.
And there was one television in my village
while we were growing up.
And we got to watch two TV shows.
One was a local drama called "Generations"
and the other one was wrestling.
- That's amazing.
- Yes, so if I didn't go by Sho Madjozi I would've
gone by John Cena probably.
As I learned back then that's already someone's name
so I didn't.
But I love him.
- You didn't steal it?
I love it I love it.
- And I made the song cause it's really about,
you know cause John Cena always used to say, "You can't
see me"?
So when we used to play wrestling with my cousins
I used to pretend to be John Cena.
- Oh my gosh I love you.
(Sho laughs)
- I just pictured you like eight years old
just like giving it to em.
I love that.
- I just be like, "You can't see me" ya know.
And so yeah, so then recently I had this boy
that I really like and then he just didn't
notice me ever so I was like, "Man, this guy can't
see me maybe--
- I don't like him already.
- Thank you, I was like, "He can't see me, maybe
I'm John Cena".
(everyone laughs)
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
That's amazing.
So did you ever actually get to meet him?
After you did this?
- Who?
- John Cena?
Oh no, of course not, not yet.
I hope I meet him one day.
- [Kelly] Oh yeah, well that's a bummer.
I mean I think he posted, didn't he post
about it as well when he found out?
- I don't know if he posts for himself
but his page, he put the picture of me on there.
And he doesn't say anything, he doesn't caption,
he doesn't tag me, nothing.
- He's...
Because you can't see him.
(everyone laughs)
(audience claps)
- But I love him.
I don't know when I don't know what will happen
cause if I see him I'm gonna freak out.
- [Kelly] You're gonna die? Okay.
- I love him a lot yeah.
- All right well it's our first season he's not here.
We have a small budget but--
- He's probably watching,
- But wait, say he's watching and he's gonna love
this moment and I want you to perform the song,
will you?
- Oh yay.
- Okay, let's perform.
(applause)
- You come on over here.
(upbeat music)
- Hey.
Sho.
(sings in foreign language)
♪ I don't know why you treat me like a criminal ♪
♪ Hey, we were just together though ♪
♪ On the same line, why you pressin' enter though? ♪
♪ Some wanna act rough like John Cena ♪
♪ Some wanna get buff like John Cena ♪
♪ We used to be cool, when I used to come through ♪
♪ Now you wanna act tough like John Cena ♪
♪ Chi chi chi chi ♪
♪ Chi chi chi ♪
♪ Some wanna act rough like John Cena ♪
♪ Some wanna get-- ♪
(sho screams)
(audience cheers)
- [Sho] What do you mean?
You said he's not here.
What is happening?
(kelly laughs)
- [Sho] You said he's not here.
(audience cheers)
(sho screams)
- John Cena, nice--
- Holy cow, holy cow
- [John] Nice to meet you.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- What.
- We'll be right back.
(upbeat music)
- So, what do you wanna say to Sho?
She loves you.
- [Sho] Oh my.
- First of all thank you for the kind words
while I was hiding back there.
I was hiding the whole time.
I do post myself and I don't caption anything
because I kind of don't want the viewer
of the account to--
I want them to take away what they can
and people are finding inspiration in your song.
And here's what you don't know.
She explained it very candidly but her song
is about, essentially about heartbreak right?
- Yeah
- But it's really cool because it's a high energy song
and you can take something negative in your life
and express it creatively and you've literally
reached an audience around the world.
- [Sho] Oh my gosh
- I think that is super, super empowering
- And super, super influencing.
- [Kelly] John Cena you are so well spoken.
- But no that's the truth, here we are
in Los Angeles she's from South Africa,
geographically around the world.
And you managed to create a dance challenge
in my name and we saw that I can't dance.
We just saw that, just saw that.
(everyone laughs)
- But wait, you used to rap.
- You did the impossible.
- [Sho] You were a rapper yeah.
- Yeah you used to rap, would you ever
do a song with Sho?
I'm just saying.
- I still got some bars.
(everyone cheers)
- I'm 42, I don't I don't.
At all.
- [Kelly] That's what would make it awesome.
- But for you, for you, yes.
- You're the best, I can't believe this.
- Is this the real one?
- That is the real, it's not a fake, it's not a fake.
- So that's weird right?
It's John Cena, is that the real John Cena?
- Cause she's overwhelmed, especially, I can't imagine
being a child.
I can imagine actually.
You're a child and you grow up loving these people
and you idolize them and they change you, ya know
they've made such an impact on you
and it's awesome to get to meet them in real life
later in life.
It's the coolest thing.
- Are you kidding me?
It's hearing that song.
So I've been in WWE a long time, almost 20 years,
and you forget the impact that you have on people
and hearing that song--
like, you're cool.
I'm not.
- [Sho] Noooo.
- [Kelly] You are both cool.
- So hearing something like that kind of
makes me half cool again, which is the best thing ever.
Like really, I'm so very excited to know that
essentially what I did had an impact on people
around the world, that's also really cool.
- You're so amazing.
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] What do you want to say to John?
Now he's right in front of you.
- Yeah, here we are.
It's just us, nobody's watching let's just--
- Nobody can see you first of all.
- [John] Nobody can, who are you sitting next
to on the couch?
- The whole audience is like, "She's really excited
about that empty space".
(everyone laughs)
- Yeah, it's a WWE thing, you know what I'm talking about.
- I think you're the coolest ever.
- [John] Wow.
- I think you're the coolest ever--
- [John] Thank you.
- Like, I would have gone by John Cena if it
wasn't, if you weren't already John Cena.
- Well here's the thing, it's not really my name.
My dad's name is John Cena.
So I'm saying if you want to borrow it, it's got legs.
- What do you mean it's not your real name?
- Well it is my real name but it's not my name.
My dad's name is also John Cena so--
- Oh I thought maybe you were saying it
was your middle name.
- At family functions we have to fight to the death
just to see who gets the name for the evening.
- That's amazing.
- No but yeah go ahead use it, no you stick
with Sho Madjozi.
Everyone around the world knows Sho Madjozi.
- [Kelly] It's infectious, it's infectious.